gar nicht
es ist freitag vor der wahl und
weltweiter klima- streik in cottbus
versammelt sich ein grüppchen zur
fahrrad demo der kohleausstieg bedeutet
für sie eine chance
geben und dadurch
in der lausitz vertreten die
demonstranten eine minderheit die grünen
holten hier im wahlkreis gerade mal 55
20 kilometer weiter das dörfchen heinz
brück zwischen tagebau und dem
braunkohlekraftwerk jänschwalde das als
erstes in der lausitz abgeschaltet wird
die dorfkneipe zum deutschen haus bis
zwei tage die woche geöffnet auch am
wahlabend
die ersten hochrechnungen laufen das
interesse verhalten
mit dem ende der kohle haben sie sich in
heinz brück abgefunden doch viele
fürchten dass die lausitz wieder einmal
der große verlierer ist
und ich stehe dazu
weil
alle anderen versagt haben
gnadenlos versagt haben grüne werden für
mich hier nicht gewählt weil
arbeitsplatzvernichter sind für mich bin
gestern zufälligen treffen da war der
liter super 1 75 ist ja wohl normal aber
nur noch für strom
sowie die
zugereisten brauchen sollen in ein dass
brück kam die afg auf 44,5 den
ehrenamtlichen bürgermeister wundert das
nicht er fühlt sich selbst nicht
mitgenommen von der großen politik trotz
der angekündigten milliarden
investitionen in seiner heimat
unterlief mancher zeitungen
große innovation am kauf am standort
jänschwalde geplant donnerwetter denkt
man sich jetzt die post richtig ab und
was kommt raus eine
müllverbrennungsanlage immer gucken
mit 50 arbeitsplätze tausende gut
bezahlte jobs in der kohle fallen weg
und was danach kommt das weiß der
bürgermeister nicht
wie viel man so ein bisschen wie naja
der hinterhof wissen sie wo also alles
rinke bachmann egal wo sieht ja so für
sie einige bürger hier
thomas zenker ist auch bürgermeister in
der lausitz für die spd in der kleinen
stadt großräschen seit 27 jahren so
lange schon macht der strukturwandel
ganz praktisch was ist das hier sieht
spektakulär aus ist aber ein
quantensprung für großräschen weil
nämlich die gesamte kernstadt hier in
diesem jahr mit neun mit dem neuen
glasfasernetz durchzogen wird mitte 2022
gehe ich davon aus dass große vision
flächendeckend in der gigabit
gesellschaft angekommen ist der
bürgermeister setzt auch die
strukturhilfen für den kohleausstieg an
17 milliarden euro bekommt die lausitz
zenker hat sich fast 80 millionen
gesichert für ein tourismusprojekt und
für eine neue ausbildungsstätte auf
diesem gelände das also eine
industrielle brache ist da soll dieses
innovative lernzentrum lausitz entstehen
wo junge menschen schüler von der
siebten bis zur zwölften klasse an
zukünftige berufsbilder herangeführt
werden und wenn alles gut läuft wird
vielleicht in drei jahren das erste mal
der bagger hier stehen und das erste
objekt auch sichtbar werden es läuft
doch vor einer woche die hiobsbotschaft
die nahe gelegene fabrik von vestas
macht dicht sie baut rotorblätter für
windräder 1000 menschen arbeiteten hier
einmal doch dann wirkte die
bundesregierung den ausbau der windkraft
ab in ganz deutschland gingen
zehntausende jobs verloren auch
großräschen hat es jetzt getroffen bei
einigen ja bestätigt dass natürlich auch
den glauben an den strukturwandel und
auch an die kraft der erneuerbaren
energien denn das war ja bis jetzt immer
so das aushängeschild wenn gesagt wurde
wo werden wir zukünftig arbeiten wenn es
unsere kraft trecker und tagebauen nicht
mehr gibt noch fördern sie in der nähe
von großräschen die kohle im tagebau
welzow erst 2038 soll hier schluss sein
laut kohle kompromiss
doch mittlerweile ist klar eine
regierung die die klimaziele für
deutschland erreichen will muss
schneller raus aus der kohle
bürgermeister zenker freut sich dass
seine partei gewonnen hat und die großen
probleme kommen noch ich habe aber die
sorge dass jetzt wo es zu ganz
spannenden koalitionsverhandlungen
kommen wird dieser kohlekompromiss
sozusagen auf dem prüfstand kommen kann
oder vielleicht sogar auf den auf dem
altar geopfert werden kann danach sieht
es aus die künftigen koalitionspartner
werden druck machen schneller raus aus
der kohle und mehr jobs bei
klimafreundlichen energien nur wenn das
gelingt hat die lausitz eine chance